hello and welcome to this video playing
practicals with white I don't even know
what he is doing here Chris the French
okay I obviously have played quite a
number of games against him but mostly
and with other other setups with d4c
formal kind of things so we'll see what
happens here you place the Fort Knox
variation of the French very solid set
up so i'll just play normally clean
moves here and see what what happens
what about 95 inch LF form it's probably
not right that looks a little bit like
c6 okay
mm-hmm it doesn't look all that actor
for him but probably some some c5 is
still drink doing the trick to open this
up I wonder if I can do something real
aggressive here like f4 or something but
I don't know if it is doing all that
much at the end maybe I should just take
yeah so let's hear that it's actually
not difficult to him to play c 5 t i was
thinking night h5 rook t3 is kind of
thing maybe let's try that I mean kind
of the inventing the really a because
this is probably all well known but not
not to me so here if I take it yeah I
probably have to take it home ok so then
this is probably just equal maybe Bishop
before as an idea just try to put some
pressure on that I cannot play them get
the ticket or play c5 that easily tween
to have three these kind of things I
guess some okay
there's some Catalan tower structure
here if I take looks a little bit more
comfortable for me and then Queenie 5 or
queen GF 6 it's it's probably difficult
Queen f6 looks nice but it's still
difficult to do something really
substantial with this position and what
people take or queen c7 I don't know if
I can do something serious here
some some stuff like gyh 5 is probably
am and quite a bit too crude and wonder
I mean I'm not think I'm risking all
that much if i do it let's do it let's
do it they can go to this ending yeah
this is what i calculated enough water
with this is f5 f5 ah this is what I
didn't didn't see you beforehand I
thought he has this bad horn structure
but f5 is of course possible ok at least
I get the same pond so I should not be
terribly worse here ok I think I'm Lewis
because his King is supporting the pawns
and mine mine is not it's really an
issue am nice it would probably even
give up the a porn i will see i can i
can push my points as well rooty to g3
is kind of dangerous
rooty too I have to check out the check
while took mages bouquet for of course
here is an important important IDM
yeah I think I'm okay you're okay for
him it's quite important
he just wants to approach he just wants
to approach the pawn but if i do this i
was thinking and before we are getting
interesting interesting ending he what
is he doing f4 and stuff you just put
much as support em time morning Group
chief five that probably isn't great but
if he go see five and they go beg Luke
c14 be 5 and so on I mean this is this
kind of quick isn't it let's see what
happens here why would a position ok
takes it with the king
ha I must be okay yeah come on that
that's really not i don't i don't think
it cannot be okay here so in check let's
routinely to me just this one twenty ten
seconds King into what I can take f2 it
should at least ok Ave probably slow
better peace be six is a huge threat I
mean yes sir look up seven maybe or
something no and I played with 6k me too
and you will play a six probably check
no 30 plays a six and I'm winning black
eyes I hmm what's strange okay I thought
a six drawers I mean maybe I'm just not
calculating it right I'm not
unsurprisingly i thought a six would be
better here I but I'm just promoting of
course he I just promote sorry yeah he
cannot kill here I just promoted okay so
let's check this check this game and
yeah I didn't really get much this is
the normal
we are playing this opening and why
should have a slight edge which i
probably have but from here i'm probably
not playing it right and force
considered by the computer I'm always a
bit skeptical about this move in this in
this kind of position because I'm not
sure how much it really contributes to
the attack and the White King and the
long run can be a subject to assess c5
and the bishop coming to c5 and so
honest and this diagonal and I don't
know but the computer likes it I was
thinking even this might be on but here
five seems to work okay you know on this
kind of move five already okay and okay
it looks dangerous and dangerous so this
was probably a bit a bit too lame okay o
Queen f3 oh wow ah this is a big miss
that's a big miss of course he cannot do
this and this is a disaster yeah they
say the long diagonal is a disaster
things he I was actually thinking about
this this thing is not protected yeah
but Oliver Lee I made may be able to
spot it this again yet here this g-force
I thought the only way to spice it up a
little bit but I did cf5 too late this
is probably what he has to do this
thread or these two threats IAM are
quite quite serious so Queenie seven and
now okay the engine wants to keep this
and here I'm I don't know first my first
instinct was I'm in trouble but many
things are still kind of okay this is a
very very tough ending 5 what's the
computer moved what it it looked okay I
mean we're very okay so the computer
gives gives the draw here which is kind
of unsurprising it looks very sharp but
it could easily be the did kind of
fizzled out after some wild
complications a 6 this is the engine
slowing takes takes King d5 and I'm not
able to play v6 okay and this kind of
thing is a drawer yeah yeah this is
probably some kind of yeah position to
draw both sides cannot do much you
played this and now it seems to be
tricky at first at least engine gives me
some edge here it's very difficult for
human player to burn to to evaluate
because of the it's very sharp with the
bonds so III jack take it all so i take
it I still suspect that this is some
kind of draw actually
okay here yeah I'm winning so we had to
take with the with the pawn it feels
very counterintuitive rooty one chick
Wow pop this is a cool line I know this
one and I'm just about stopping it and
now I have to give up my porn so so far
draw only here it seems to be losing for
him top and a six didn't work I was
thinking a six works but it didn't yeah
and um I've won this game which pushed
me back over 2400 which is which is nice
to see ok guys thanks for watching